good afternoon everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be studying today is SCP 1104 object
class Keter special containment
procedures complete destruction of SCP
1104 is endorsed should adequate means
be developed while individual instances
of scp-1000 4 are easily terminated SCP
1104 is endemic to the subsurface
geological formations in northwestern
rendering the surmised primary
population of SCP 1104 and accessible to
conveniently thil agents a surrounding
area 10 kilometers in diameter has been
designated site 104 and cordoned from
the public under guise of endangered
species preservation personnel must wear
n100 air filtration masks while within
site 104 mammalian organisms exceeding
10 kilograms or than authorized
foundation personnel entering site 104
should be assumed contaminated and
incinerated and facilities on-site
description SCP 1104 is a species
tentatively identified as a member of
order Tilly's Sarada the lifecycle of
SCP 1104 comprises at least two distinct
phases the first being a larval stage
approximately 0.4 millimeters in
diameter and irregular intervals larval
SCP 1104 are expelled from lava tubes
within site 104 at concentrations up to
200 individuals per cubic metre these
remain airborne for as long as 14 hours
and have been documented to travel at
least kilometres under favourable
weather conditions
when inhaled larvae will adhere to nasal
mucosa where they excrete an array of h1
receptor antagonists that suppresses
both local inflammation and implantation
of further larvae over a period of six
to eight months SCP 11:04 will grow and
extend appendages through the hosts
ethmoidal canals hosts generally remain
unaware of the presence of SCP 1104
apart from persistent but nonspecific
headaches on mature Asian sep11 O form
will begin applying pressure to the
hosts optic nerves causing obstruction
of the central visual field this
pressure is applied selectively when the
host is not orientated toward the local
gradient of atmospheric hydrogen sulfide
which SCP 1104 can detect through the
hosts inhalations after an initial
period of distress the host will begin
to prefer to face and travel in the
directions where they do not experience
visual disturbances thus tracing the
source of hydrogen sulfide upon reaching
a zone of sufficient hydrogen sulfide
concentration SCP 1104 projects
appendages into the hosts prefrontal
cortex causing unconsciousness during
which SCP 1104 exits the host by the
ocular cavity after leaving the host SCP
1104 attempts to locate and enter the
source of hydrogen sulfide such as a
lava tube or sewer pipe SCP 1104 s
subterranean life cycle has not been
documented although humans display the
same instinctual aversion as any animal
to visual disturbances caused by a CP
11:04 the behavioral response is not a
compulsion the hosts may defy the
influence especially if informed of the
nature of SCP 1104 note that subsequent
hostility toward research personnel
should be anticipated attempts at
surgically removing or poisoning a fully
developed SCP 1104 result in immediate
elicitation of its exit response
exit hosts exhibit complete a
spontaneity due to orbital frontal
lesions and to date have provided no
pertinent information in debriefing okay
everyone that was a short I'll be an
informative lecture today thank you very
much for listening goodbye I would like
to give a special thank you to Andre
best shift
thank you very much Andre your pledge is
very much appreciated if you would like
to know how you can get a personalized
thank e at the end of each of my videos
as well as some other really cool stuff
as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
[Music]
you